Donald Trump's ethics lawyer allegedly
told a witness to the January 6 Trump
Riot committee to lie under oath this is
absolutely unbelievable CNN has an
exclusive report Trump's former White
House ethics lawyer told Cassidy
Hutchinson to give misleading testimony
to the January 6th committee according
to multiple sources look at this
the January 6th committee made a
startling allegation on Monday claiming
it had evidence that a trump-backed
attorney
urged a key witness to mislead the
committee about details they recalled
though the committee declined to
identify the people CNN has learned that
Stefan pasentino the top ethics attorney
in the Trump White House is the lawyer
who allegedly advised his then client
former White House aide Cassidy
Hutchinson to tell the committee that
she did not recall details that she did
recall source is familiar with the
committee's work tell CNN
Trump save America Pac funded pasentino
and his Law Firm elections LLC including
paying for his representation of
Hutchinson other sources tell CNN the
committee report notes the lawyer did
not tell his client who was paying for
the legal services
when asked about pressure on Hutchinson
after Monday's hearing Committee Member
representative zoloftgren told CNN she
was advised to say she didn't recall
something when she did so that's pretty
serious stuff the episode is just one of
several instances in which the committee
has accused members of Trump's orbit of
trying to obstruct the panel's
investigation
this is extraordinarily serious if true
if a lawyer were to tell a congressional
witness to lie under oath it could
potentially constitute the crime of
perjury or the related offense of
suborning of perjury or maybe
subordination of perjury which is the
act of inducing someone to commit
perjury and it's important to note that
the specific legal consequences of that
depend on the details of the case the
applicable law the circumstances what
you can prove is often the case when it
comes to perjury etc etc now you and I
of course recognize the kind of
oxymoronic nature of a trump ethics
lawyer I I get that we're not even going
to focus in on that but this is sort of
like a third layer of what is going on
with the Trump riots because you have
sort of at the top of the food chain as
the case may be at the top of the
pyramid is the riot itself and who was
involved in inciting and the planning of
that Riot that's number one number two
is you have the witnesses
at the Trump Riot committee hearings and
whether they told the truth or lied
whether they were tampered with Etc
the third layer now is were there other
people
influencing the testimony of the
witnesses at the January 6 Committee
hearing about the Trump riots and who
incited those so you've got like Trump
inciting the riot and then you've got
Cassidy Hutchinson testifying about what
she saw in terms of who was inciting or
talking about or trying to dissuade the
writers and now we have a third level
which is who influenced Cassidy
Hutchinson's testimony and potentially
told her to say she doesn't recall
things that she actually does recall
about that top layer of the pyramid we
now have three layers to this pyramid
the fourth layer
maybe is like the rioters themselves in
some way it starts to get
extraordinarily complicated but this is
already above and beyond anything that
we have seen in the history of the
United States part of the difference is
in an era of records for communication
and text messages an event that was on
camera and on and on that makes it
different in terms of our ability to
actually see and figure out what went on
and that's understandable but there has
never been anything like this in
American history and so we are going to
at some point uh see if and when the
justice department decides to act on
those criminal referrals that have
already been sent forward and that
applies to Donald Trump as we learned
earlier this week John Eastman the
lawyer and others but there's this whole
other layer which is what about all of
the perjury that is suspected among some
of the witnesses and then who got to
them and was there indeed with witness
tampering one of the things that was
also alleged during
maybe it was the second to last or what
one of the kind of later public hearings
of the January 6 committee was that
there were individuals there were
multiple instances of individuals
reaching out to Witnesses and allegedly
trying to intimidate or tamper I don't
believe we ever actually fully got to
the bottom of that I don't think this
example is the the full scope of that
and that's just another layer that needs
to be investigated unfortunately the
January 6 committee is going to end
because this session of Congress is
ending and then Republicans are taking
over they don't want to look into the
riots they want to look into stuff like
the genitalia of Hunter Biden and stuff
like that so things are going to change
dramatically but we will hopefully get
to the bottom of this component and
again Trump ethics lawyer I don't know
of any uh greater oxymoron than that